okay so everyone my name is Aoi haneun I
am at by do research
actually at the Silicon Valley AI lab
which is part of the broader by do
research and like Andy said today I'm
gonna talk about speech recognition and
in particular focus on how we've been
using deep learning edid research to to
make progress in speech recognition so I
guess the thing that we're really
interested in doing at ed at the Silicon
Valley AI lab is really solving speech
recognition right
and when I say solving speech
recognition I think what I mean and what
we mean is not that it kind of works
sometimes when you're holding your phone
really close to your mouth and maybe
you're speaking like particularly slowly
and clearly
and like loudly so that it understands
you and you have to say the same thing a
couple of times what we mean rather is
that speech recognition works and say a
robust or wide array of contexts so a
couple of examples might be say one
you're driving right and you put your
phone on your passenger seat and there's
a lot of noise because cars are noisy
and and maybe the windows are down maybe
the radio is on in speech recognition
isn't gonna work there most of the time
and I certainly know that humans work
really well there like they can
recognize my speech so why can't a
machine another example might be say I'm
watching TV and I'm sitting kind of far
away from the television and the TV is
on right so it's even creating its own
noise if there's volume coming out of
the TV speech wrecking to TV using my
voice like using speech as my interface
that's not going to work so that's what
I mean when I say soft speech
recognition those are the kinds of
examples that we're thinking about
okay so deep speech is kind of the
latest and greatest research coming out
of Baidu to try and tackle these sorts
of problems
okay so here's an outline of the things
I'm going to cover and actually my goal
was to talk about deep speech like
when I came to do this I wanted to
mostly talk about deep speech but I
actually realized that a lot of you are
not experts in speech recognition and a
lot of you depending on when you were
born are also not experts in deep
learning so I'm going to spend probably
most of the time actually just talking
about what's going on in the world with
speech recognition so I'll first get
into kind of where does speech where
speech recognition used what why does it
work why does it not work and and how
does it work for that matter I'll get
into some of the details of how does it
actually work assembly
similarly for deep learning I'll talk
about some of the the details of keep
learning hopefully without getting lost
in the the technical weeds this is a
little easy to do with deep learning but
I'll also get into some of the
applications and hopefully leave you
guys with some intuition for why why it
works so well or why it's so popular
right now at this point hopefully you
guys should have enough context about
speech recognition deep learning and
then I will get into deep speech and
talk about some of the key ingredients
that we have been using to scale up
steep learning and speech recognition
and really solve some of these or make
progress I should say on some of these
problems the last thing is I'll just
briefly cover some next steps both in
terms of our research directions but
also for you guys if you're interested
in learning more for those of you that
don't already know a lot about deep
learning or speech recognition and I
think if these these seminar series are
usually pretty interactive so you know
don't hesitate to interrupt me with
questions as I'm talking at any point so
I'm good okay so let's get started okay
so the state of speech recognition so as
I alluded to earlier with a couple of
examples there are still many failure
modes of speech recognition one of the
biggest failure modes at least in my in
my experience is and kind of with some
quantitative backing is low
signal-to-noise ratio
so low lessen our signal-to-noise ratio
can be brought about for several reasons
perhaps the most easy to see is when
there's a lot of background noise so
imagine that you guys were all talking
right now and I wanted to have my phone
recognize my speech there's gonna be a
lot of noise so it's gonna be less clear
to the phone what the actual signal is
that it should be focusing on right well
that's an art can also be brought about
for a couple of other reasons so so one
reason I guess is what's called
far-field speech recognition so in the
in the TV example that I mentioned
earlier where you're kind of sitting far
away from your television right the
microphone is actually going to be in
the television and maybe you're ten feet
away from it so the signal is going to
die out before it has a chance to at
least it will partially die out before
has a chance to get all the way to that
microphone talking yeah that would be a
source of background noise right yeah
another potential source of low SNR is
what's called reverberation so just like
echo basically when when you're trying
to speak into a microphone right like
some of the sound goes straight towards
the microphone but a lot of it actually
bounces off random places like say the
walls are you know you guys and well
eventually arrived back at the
microphone but it will just arrive at a
slightly later time so the the signal is
going to get kind of smeared out and
that's it that's a source of noise -
okay so that's low SNR that's one big
failure mode of speech recognition
another big failure mode is speaker
variability so actually so Adam Coates
who's the director of the lab that I'm a
part of the Silicon Valley Iowa he told
me this fun story of how it has a friend
who was really excited when we published
our deep speech results because his
friend has a really thick Italian accent
and no speech recognizers work for this
guy like none of the ones on the market
and he was hoping that deep speech would
help make progress on this we still have
a lot of work cut out to solve this
problem but we're hoping that it will
make progress on it as well
appreciate so accents is one source of
speaker variability it's not the only
source though I mean other sources might
be differences in age differences in
gender even the length of your vocal
tract which varies just on a human to
human basis can make the signal look
very different to a machine so some of
these were actually already pretty good
at sorry yes the tork multilingual you
know English is one thing but Mandarin
yeah so that's a good that's a good
question
right now I'm mostly talking about
English speech recognition and generally
like there have not been good solutions
for one type of recognizer which can
recognize multiple languages you kind of
have to instantiate different
recognizers for different languages
that said though I believe that our
algorithm if you were to take it and
plop you know a bunch of Mandarin data I
believe it would work and that's things
that we're kind of looking into doing
the absence if you know what the accent
came from yeah potentially but sometimes
it's hard to know where the accent came
from right cool so speaker variability
is another big field your method of
speech a third one is just natural and
conversational speech so when you're
talking to your phone right you're
speaking in a really effective manner
like almost like you're reading off of a
sheet of paper into your phone or like
you were like scolding a two-year-old or
something you're speaking really loudly
and slowly so conversational speech is
like the other side of that if I were
trying to transcribe like a phone
conversation that two of us might have
or or even me talking right now
transcribing this is actually quite hard
for a machine and the reason that is is
because I actually change a lot of my
property at the properties of speech as
I'm talking in a natural way like the
tempo
I changed the rate at which I speak
sometimes I speak really quickly
sometimes I speak more slowly without
even thinking about it
other things that I do are are called
they're called discipline menses and
these are things like starting and
stopping a word without finishing it or
these sorts of things that you don't you
don't typically do when you're dictating
into your phone but you might you might
do or you actually always do when you're
speaking naturally okay so those are
some of the failure modes of speech
recognition now actually recently Google
actually published that I found a really
interesting analysis on where people are
currently using speech recognition and
they split it into two demographics
teens and adults as you can see here so
the the biggest place was for mostly for
both groups was amongst friends
another really surprising place was in
the bathroom I'm not entirely sure what
people are doing with speech recognition
in the bathroom but all right so they're
using speech recognition in the bathroom
other places are as you can see like
while exercising while cooking more so
while cooking adults than teens which
makes sense but all of these places are
you can imagine easily places where you
would expect a lot of noise learn this
I think surveys but I can't recall I
have this this link here if you're
curious to know more about the study you
can follow that I think they will give
more details yep so those are some of
the places that people are using speech
recognition they also oh sorry they also
they also published some of the tasks
that people achieve with speech
recognition so the most common of these
tasks were such things as trying to call
someone on your phone so I would say
like call Jesse and Jesse might be in my
contact book others were where I think
here you see like check the time setting
your alarm I don't think that's on the
list but that's kind of in the same
bucket but you might notice looking at
these tasks they have kind of one thing
in common and that's that they're all
very very simple right
you don't need a huge vocabulary to
understand these types of things and and
thus they're actually really easy for
typically much easier for a machine to
do at least to transcribe your your
speech then then would be say something
like composing a text message or
transcribing a voicemail or transcribing
like a lecture for example and those
things aren't really at least in terms
of how people are using their phones for
speech recognition they're not up on the
list not even close and that's because
speech recognition doesn't really work
there yet all right so I don't know if
you guys have noticed but I've certainly
noticed a lot of devices coming out
lately that are essentially driven in
their interfaces with only speech
recognition so I saw one of these
smartwatches earlier which you can I
think swipe you know side to side on
them but if you want to interact with
them in a meaningful way the way to do
it is with speech right and that's not a
seamless process
I don't think and that's because speech
recognition doesn't work very well so
it's it'd be cool to be able to you know
like talk to your wife as you're walking
and compose a text message but that's
not a news case that is very common yeah
Baidu has this really cool product
called Baidu I which is the one up here
on the upper right and you wear this
thing around your head
right there on the back of your head and
it's got a camera on your right ear and
a speaker in your left ear and it can
kind of see and perceive things in your
field of vision and the way that you
communicate with it is via speech
recognition solely with speech
recognition and then it talks to your
phone via bluetooth so for that to be a
seamless experience we need to really
make progress on at least the natural
and low SNR failure modes of speech
recognition I'm not sure if you guys
have seen this probably have the Amazon
echo essentially a smart speaker which
can do things like let's see it can you
can add things to your shopping cart
with it say like echo add milk to my
shopping cart
or or you can ask it to play music you
can say echo turn on some pop music but
the funny thing is anecdotally I've
heard that when you ask the Amazon echo
to turn on music it starts playing music
and creates kind of a cloud noise around
itself and you can no longer communicate
with it because the speech isn't gonna
work anymore so this is a problem right
we need to make progress in the noisy
setting the other cool thing about
Amazon echo actually I think well the
other interesting thing is that it has
seven microphones and the reason that it
has all of these microphones is because
it uses all of them to kind of zoom in
on who it's trying to listen to this is
a technique called beamforming which
which allows it to use multiple
microphones to find the source of signal
but I think this is interesting because
we as humans we only really have two
microphones right we just have our two
years and yet we're able to transcribe
speech much much better than the Amazon
echo so I think this suggests to me that
there's something algorithmic that's
missing from from this picture shaped
our user shape nicely it's this true yep
it's probably pretty important and we
have a lot of infrastructure going on in
here that I'm glossing over when I say
our ears are identical the two
microphones this is true but we
certainly only had two sources
okay so here's some some kind of history
obsolete recognition over over the past
half century or so I hope I got this
right
so the the early days of speech it was
really trivial like you would just take
a single word template match it against
your database of other words and that's
the only thing you could do this so
speech recognition improved to the
primarily what I think are two
breakthroughs two big sources of steep
improvement in performance right so if
you look at over the year you see kind
of these two humps where speech
recognition really got a lot better and
the first was it quite such a
crystal-clear hump but it was
primarily due to the introduction of
hidden Markov models and speech
recognition the hidden Markov models are
basically a way of statistically
understanding time series data and over
the 70s to the present day
they have been at the core of all speech
recognition technology and have allowed
it to improve more recently the
introduction of deep learning to one of
the small components of well a large
component but a sub component of the
speech recognition pipeline you see this
in 2012 actually increased performance a
lot but other than that most improvement
has been actually pretty marginal and
it's low and I don't I don't know about
you guys but I don't want to wait
another you know 40 years for the next
big improvement in speech recognition so
we're asking ourselves the question of
like how can we get another one of these
big big breakthroughs in speech
recognition how would you say that the
apartment performance improvements
happen like a lot of the claims from
early artificial intelligence work were
really only because of device individual
device speed-up
yeah it's a Harvard technology get a
software guys climate you know over
claimed a lot of things I think that's
totally fair I think basically
everything you see from hmm onward is
more so yeah I think that's true like
the reason we were able to do large
vocabulary continuous speech recognition
in the 90s didn't have anything to do
with changing down underlying algorithms
for the most part just because we can
now just deep learning gives you a feel
slightly better higher jump then I'm not
I'm not implicitly suggesting that in
this picture I don't know it's not
trying to see you yeah sorry and even
deep learning you could argue that I
mean neural networks have been around
for a long time right you could argue
that now we can actually train them
successfully because of the hardware
that's a little bit to this
by saying successfully what's that
McDreamy sorry you didn't you are you're
assuming it I'll just say that you can
train them successfully
you can certainly train right right okay
so how does speech recognition work
today well it all starts when I record
some snippet of audio someone saying
something and I put it into a machine
and then that audio goes into an
acoustic model so the job of the
acoustic model is actually to predict
what phonemes might be present in the
audio so sound is at least human speech
is made up of phonemes and the job of
the acoustic model is to guess what
phonemes you might have just said those
phonies then go into a phony model and
the job of the phony model is to try to
make sense of what words might be
present in the guest phonemes from the
acoustic model and those words those
predicted words essentially go into the
language model and the job of the
language model is to assign higher
probability to words that are likely to
co-occur together and lower probability
to words that are unlikely to kill occur
together so an example might be like say
I said the cat set and the hat set the
cat set is much more probable because
the captain said but the hat set sounds
similar so maybe the acoustic model and
the phoneme model didn't get it but the
language model can come in and say no
that that couldn't possibly have been
said because the hat set doesn't make
any sense so from that I'm able to get
an output transcription it's sort of
very high level that's how that's the
the pipeline and I actually want to get
a bit more into the acoustic model
because that's where a lot of the kind
of the magic of today's state-of-the-art
speech recognition happens so what's
going on in the acoustic model
okay so the first step is the stage in
the stage called feature extraction so
essentially what this stage is doing is
taking the time domain audio and
converting it into a frequency domain
but it's not just doing a simple for you
to transform it's a it's it's trying to
use trying to take insights from how
humans hear actually how we perceive
sound and use that knowledge to better
extract relevant features from the audio
so the simplest thing is that we
actually only hear between I think 2 and
20,000 kilohertz
so anything outside of the frequency 20
sorry anything outside of to 20 and
20,000 Hertz I misspoke anything outside
of 20,000 Hertz we're going to just cut
off right because humans can't hear that
so presumably there's no useful speech
in that in that range the other
interesting thing about the way humans
here is we actually hear on a non linear
scale as we increase frequency so we
might hear the difference between 100
and 200 Hertz in the same way that we
hear the difference between say 10,000
and 20,000 Hertz so we're going to take
account that nonlinear scale it's called
the Mel scale in speech recognition
we're going to take that into account
when we extract features okay it's
similar it's someone it's not quite a
long scale code because it also like
similar nonlinearities when it comes to
volume and stuff like that really
decibel does that have a notable
improvement than just working in the log
scale yes it has in the past you'll see
that we don't actually use this
currently for deep speech so I would
argue that if you I'll be parking later
and I will argue later that if you have
enough data and the right model is
probably not yes so okay so feature
extraction and then the next stage after
feature extraction the feature
extraction module sends a role that
features to speaker adaptation and I
mentioned earlier that speaker
variability is a source of problem first
recognition and so people so one thing
we can try to do is to try to kind of
push our features towards a global
speaker or you can also think of it as
trying to remove the speaker specific
effects of the sound out and try to make
everything look the same to them up and
they have fairly advanced statistical
methods for doing this
but they are still very much prone to
error and accents are actually still
very hard for them so the next step
after speaker adaptation is a it's the
phoneme prediction and this is the part
here the phoneme prediction which
currently is done with deep neural
networks and the job of that module is
essentially to given the speaker adapted
features predict what phoneme might be
present so the the phony prediction
model doesn't have to be a deep neural
network I should say it just has to be
any supervised machine learning
algorithm now I'll actually get more
into what that means in a minute but
first you guys have any more questions
about the state of speech recognition
yes indication of how much CPU version
each of these steps yeah so feature
extraction is pretty cheap I mean if you
have a huge data set you're gonna use a
lot of CPUs because so to your question
it's hard to answer your question in a
generic framework but if I am if I am
just going to speak to my my phone and I
want it to recognize that speech and
just like the one example case then the
feature extraction is pre cheap like I
can do that extremely quickly with a
single thread the speaker adaptation
likewise the problem with speaker
adaptation is not the computational
complexity of it or the expense but
actually knowing who the speaker is and
knowing enough properties about that
speaker to then remove the wrote the
information that is kind of different
about that speaker yes however we know
that phonemes are the right things to be
looking for we don't and I'm gonna tell
you that they're not high
brother not quite but it like so let me
just finish answering your question the
last the last part the phony prediction
model is actually the most expensive and
and they still typically do this with
just single CPUs with one example a
single thread one one CPU box of three
or four on the previous slide right as
in this slide here so that that the
acoustic modeling is by far the most
expensive part that's not sure actually
the acoustic modeling is expensive and
then you have to do this process of
decoding in order to actually retrieve
the correct word again most of this
stuff is typically done with a single
thread and it can be done and so we kind
of have this way of measuring speech is
called like factor real time so if I'm
speaking can I do like a half real time
with a machine transcribing my speech
and a half real time and usually
production recognizers can do production
speech recognizers can do something like
70% real-time with a single CPU yes this
stuff like noise cancellation and
because of were you wrapping all that
into the teacher instruction so no I
wasn't there there is very the problem
with noise cancellation is that
different Hardware sometimes does it in
different ways even on the front end
before we see the signal in the speech
recognizer
so typically speech recognizers don't
even try to do any kind of noise
cancellation they just take the signal
and assume it's been improperly scrubbed
from those thing like in the case of the
speaker that you mentioned like it knows
what song is playing and so pathetically
just zero that yeah I think a lot of the
methods that they use now are attempting
to do this without explicitly kind of
saying that we're removing like this
type of background noise yes is it these
boxes which one is kind of the most
important to improving the output
recognition that's a great question I
think one reason that speech recognition
is hard to improve upon is be
there are so many sub modules and it's
hard to probe the system and actually
say if I change this one I will get much
better results so I'm gonna show you our
system in a little bit which tries to
just replace this whole thing and we
don't have we don't suffer from this
problem of having to figure out exactly
where the failure is occurring in the
pipeline yes you guys employed science
not more than just stealing a few few
words that they're dialect I'm kind of
gonna be careful to say yes but because
a lot of the stuff we talked about in
deep learning is very very loosely
inspired from you know like neuroscience
concepts about the human brain but very
very loosely so any other questions okay
so let's move on so deep learning great
okay
so deep learning is at the core of deep
learning is what are called artificial
neural networks and it's so called deep
because we take kind of many of these
neural networks and stack them on top of
each other you can think of it and at
the core of an artificial neural network
is is a neuron they're made up of these
little sub components these little
neurons
what's happening here is we have some
some input this could be anything like
if I had an image this would be pixels
say or if I had a speech this would be
the frequent that amount of frequency at
each at each band and so I have some
input I scale that input along these
connections or synapses and the W 1 W 2
W 3 w 4 that represents actually the
strength of these connections so I scale
the input by the strength of those
connections
yeah work exactly multiply okay that's
all I mean they can be negative and I
take literally take w4 x expert that's
what I mean and there's no constraint on
what these numbers can be other than
when we actually turned to our problem
domain what are the constraints there
okay so I then take the results of that
I sum them together I ever get them and
I apply what's called a threshold in on
to that so I I kind of squashed the
output and then if it's above a certain
threshold I kind of treat it as this
neuron being on and if it's below a
certain threshold I treat it as this
neuron getting off okay the threshold so
in practice we don't actually determine
the threshold we just let it be soft
it's a soft spec it's a nice analogy
though because you can think of this
neuron as activating when the input the
aggregated scaled input is large enough
and not activating when it's small
enough but when it comes to actually
training these things we treat this as a
soft function and that makes it easy to
for mathematical reasons it makes it
easy I mean sorry
I mean continuous right that's what I
mean and differentiable but this again
there are caveats to this this isn't
always the case so you can have lots of
things here the simplest thing you can
have is something that say squash is
your input between 0 & 1 and if it's
above a half turns it on and if it's
below a half turns it off but that's not
then that's not what's usually okay okay
so we get some output from this neuron
okay so what do I actually want to do
with this neuron well let me just take a
brief aside and tell you guys about
supervised learning for those of you
that I know probably a lot of you
already know a lot about supervised
learning but just so everyone's on the
same page okay so
say that my goal is to recognize an
image in this case an image of a copy
note the way that I'm going to do that
is I'm going to take some kind of
algorithm we call it a learning
algorithm and the only thing that this
algorithm has to do is be able to kind
of tune its internal state based on data
and then and then I'm going to actually
get a bunch of examples of images with
or without coffee mugs present and
supposedly I'm going to get a human to
label these images as having coffee mug
or not having coffee mug okay and I'm
going to take these images and I'm going
to show them one at a time to my
learning algorithm and after seeing a
bunch of these images coffee mugs are
not coffee mugs hopefully it learns
what's relevant to predicting a coffee
mug and then I can show it an image that
it's never seen before without a label
and it should correctly classify this
images having a comment all of them here
are coffee mugs but it's it's good to
have non-examples there's a good point
yes okay so supervised learning now I
can actually take my neuron and in order
to use it as a supervised learning
algorithm I can then feed an image into
it and if I correctly classify this as a
coffee mug then what I can do is try to
determine what features of this image
were important to correctly classifying
it so say that you know if X 1 X 2 X 3
and X 4 just the pixels of this image
right there's probably way more than
four pixels but assume that they're just
these four then I can try to determine
that say X 1 and X 3 where the relevant
pixels to me predict correctly
predicting this was a coffee mug and
then I can increase the strength of the
synapses or literally increase the value
of W 1 and W 3 so that I'm more likely
to predict that it's a coffee mug next
time
flipside suppose that incorrectly
predicted that it was not a coffee mug
well I'm just going to do the same thing
I'm gonna try to find which way it's for
responsible for this and decrease the
scale from those so I find which
features were responsible and decrease
the weights for those features now at
prediction time what I can do very
simple again it's just taking image of a
coffee mug that I haven't seen feed it
through this neuron if the neuron turns
on in this case if it is greater than
1/2
I will classify it as a copy mode and if
it's less than 1/2 I will not okay
so it turns out that I can actually make
these things much more complex this
model this neuron and I can do that in a
couple ways one is by wiring many of
these neurons together so you see here
I've just added another neuron and the
this layer here I can also stack these
layers right so I can have layer 1 layer
2 layer 3 and I can do this in arbitrary
amounts right like I can add as many
neurons here as I want in each layer and
have as many layers as I like you know
I'm limited here by computation and data
mostly so what's that anti cyclic
typically it's better if it's a if it's
anti psych if it's a dag if it's
directed and there's no cycles yeah
typically that's better yeah so there's
only one threshold here what do you Lois
before there's 4 ok 30 in theory it
could be but usually you choose one per
layers sure yep okay so instead show you
guys this image from now on when I'm
talking about a neural network I'm gonna
show you something that looks like this
the same thing just a slightly higher
abstraction of neurons in one layer
neurons in another layer and these fat
arrows just mean that all the neurons in
the first layer kind of densely
connected every pairwise connection
between neurons in each layer ok and
on the far I guess left are the input on
the far right is the output and
everything in the middle we're gonna
call hidden layers and they're so-called
hidden because we don't actually see
them or look at them when we're using
this model and this is this this model
is going to be deep when say I have
maybe more than one or two hidden layers
and shallow otherwise okay yes to use in
practice varies quite a lot for for the
problem that I'm talking about speech
recognition typically in the five to
seven range but that also gets a bit
hairier when you look at the model I'll
show you in a minute
called recurrent Network I'll give it to
it yes I know it varies a lot but
vertically how many do you have ish so
like a 50 or a million
Oh usually the small number of thousands
neurons in each layer but again that can
vary a lot yeah
depending on the problem yes yeah there
is an intelligent way and the most
intelligent way is to do what's called
cross-validation okay so are you guys
mostly familiar with cross-validation
well let me just explain for those mute
though you take kind of a part of your
data set that you are not training your
algorithm on and you try to tune the
parameters such as the number of layers
and the number of neurons based on how
well you're doing on the part that
you're not actually teaching your
learning algorithm on okay I mean I
would say that you know cross-validation
will get you a little bit but there's
also a lot of kind of like black art
into having intuition about what these
models should look like that comes with
experience okay
so why do party all right I mean the
short answer is I don't think anybody
really knows why I did morning like I'm
not gonna give you a very specific
answer but if you look at if you look at
some examples or some kind of anecdotal
evidence at least and say you're looking
at kind of traditional machine learning
algorithms well I guess I should say
machine learning supervised machine
learning algorithms other than deep
learning what you often see is as we
increase the amount of training data the
data with which we are teaching the
algorithm performance actually starts to
saturate so we get marginal returns on
say doubling the amount of training data
now the thing about deep learning that
we've noticed is that if we increase the
amount of training data actually it
keeps improving so if you guys kind of
take away one insight about deep
learning I think it should be this slide
and let me just tell you what this slide
is and what it isn't what this light is
is in the supervised learning regime
when we have data and we have the
corresponding labels and we have a lot
of it deep learning usually or probably
it's going to work really well for you
on the flip side of that when we're all
the way over here what's that
hesitation that worries me I mean I
can't answer you with a hundred I
guarantee I can tell you that it will
probably work off so you've not hit the
C oh not yeah yeah did you have a
question back I was just wondering this
is just a different scale if you move
yeah I servers there's some on you know
fundamentally mathematical difference
that makes it always scale up right so
I'll tell you where we are right now
from my experience we have big models we
have lots of data if I had more data and
I couldn't make my model bigger
that would be a good thing and the
things that are living limiting me are
more data and a computational power to
actually make my model bigger right to
be able to do that in a reasonable
amount of time so we certainly I don't
think have hit the the ceiling
although you're probably right like
probably eventually you can stop
learning I mean all these things have a
limited capacity they don't have an
infinite capacity okay yes I'm just
questioning like but one thing about
deep networks though is that they have a
lot of free parameters so do you think
that your your other plot would apply to
something like nearest neighbor where
nearest neighbor number equals four and
then if you have all the data in the
world you can still do a pretty good job
with some noise assumptions yeah I mean
I think there's a trade-off there so
more free parameters isn't necessarily
going to give you this kind of behavior
right there's something else going on
with deep learning that it that were is
allowing us to have this kind of
behavior so we can take a lot of
supervised learning algorithms just like
like say I take a logistic regression
just a simple a simple learning
algorithm and I just throw more
parameters at it that's like and and I
do this by like putting it into a higher
dimensional feature space for example
that's not gonna work as well right like
it's deep learning the same amount of
data and the reason for that I'll try to
give a little bit of intuition about is
the hierarchical structure of these
models allows them to do a lot with
relatively less data then then say
something like nearest neighbors which
is it's really hard to come up with
enough data to make that model work
really really well yes the neural
network starts to gain over other
simpler models that's a tough one to
answer I think it really depends on the
on the domain so with with computer
vision something on the order of
millions of images with speech
recognition something on the order of
many thousands of hours of speech but
again like this could be like it's hard
to even say how those two things
correspond to each other
I think one kind of rule of thumb people
use in practice is is look for every
kind of parameter you're trying to learn
you should have ten examples in your
dataset performance again in the various
dependent dependent and depending on the
test right so let me give a couple of
examples and hopefully level this is a
very general idea of performance so in
computer vision one place that deep
learning has actually worked really
really well and a contest in computer
vision is like the one I described to
you guys earlier which might be take
this image and correctly classify if
there's a coffee mug or not and so the
way that this has typically worked is I
have my first step in my pipeline and
it's very distinct and standalone step
it is feature extraction so I as a human
I'm gonna look at the problem you're
gonna look at these images and try to
think oh edges happen to be really
important to my understanding of this
image to my correct classification so
then I'm gonna try to hand design some
kind of algorithm which can detect the
edges in this image or perhaps I noticed
that like circular objects are really
important because it's a coffee mug so
I'm gonna again try to hand design some
kind of circular object detector which
can then extract where the circular
objects are and how big they are
from this image and then those are gonna
be features so instead of taking raw
pixels of this image like this image is
essentially pixels instead of taking
those I'm gonna try to extract from
those the features which I believe are
relevant and I'm gonna feed those
features into my learning algorithm here
which will enable me to make a
prediction so those are two very
distinct steps so we have here design
features and a learning algorithm so it
turns out that if instead of trying to
hand design these features myself I just
ripped that component out of the system
and instead of feeding that into
learning algorithm I just replace the
whole pipeline with a deep neural
network
which reads directly from the raw pixels
that actually works much much better and
in this case my metric for performance
is how accurate I am incorrectly
classifying objects so one thing that I
think is pretty cool is we can actually
look at the different layers of this
network and we can kind of probe the
different layers and try to see what's
going on and then so say that I had a
data set of faces like like this face
that you see here of Barack Obama and I
then take my neural network and I probe
its lower layers and I ask the question
of the network I say what do the lower
layer neurons respond to in these images
what excites then well it turns out what
what excites them is edges and edges at
different rotations and different
positions but its edges now if I ask the
same question of say the middle layers
in the network they might be excited by
face parts then they actually this is
real I mean these aren't fabricated
images so the middle layers might be
excited by say eyes or ears for example
different subcomponents of faces then if
I ask the same question about the higher
layers it turns out they might be
excited by even different faces or faces
in different positions so they will
learn to discriminate different faces so
you this really cool notion of like
levels of abstraction they're happening
within the network and all of this is
happening without me ever explicitly
saying to the network like learn edges
in the lower layers learn face parts in
the middle layers and then learn
specific faces and upper layers what I
do is I give it a data set of faces and
perhaps the witch face that is a label
and then I just look learning algorithm
learn what's relevant from that image to
correctly classify that face
okay so that's the point of your
computer vision so now if you're saying
yeah the computation is quite different
I'm not going to get intelligent exactly
what I know the order of magnitude of
computation between these two different
algorithms right as in when you use the
warning we use this like CPU half an
hour the other one
yeah I've seconds yeah so the naive
methods for doing this yeah you would
find that this took a lot longer a lot
more computation power but but people
have made a lot of progress on how to do
this and quickly and using less
computational resources and I'll talk a
little bit about that in a second yes
that's a good question and the way that
it knows that is it's really there's a
hard question to answer because though
there's an algorithm for it it's called
back propagation and basically what it
allows you to do is differentiate this
entire network with respect to each
individual parameter and then use a
learning algorithm called gradient
descent to try to learn each individual
weight I don't think I should get more
into the details of that but if you're
if you're curious about more we can talk
so ok speech recognition so this is what
I showed you guys earlier this is kind
of the state of speech recognition in
the world and what I mentioned also
earlier is that we're deep learning has
kind of taken hold in the speech
recognition pipeline is in the acoustic
modeling stage so the stage we're giving
a where I'm given a snippet of audio and
my goal is to classify what phony in
that audio is so we've successfully
replaced that module with deep learning
and that actually has resulted in a lot
of improvement in speech recognition so
you know drawing on computer vision as
an inspiration and a lot of other stuff
people done with deep learning what we'd
like to do
is just replace the whole pipeline with
deep learning with just one big neural
network which goes right from input to
output and deep speech by news system I
mean keep this slide in mind because
this is kind of our inspiration for deep
speech we haven't completely done this
but we've made we've taken a couple
steps in this direction so there's one
kind of problem that you'll encounter
when you're trying to do this with audio
and that's what I call the variable
length problem and so if you guys I
guess it's pretty clear not all audio
snippets are the same length right so
when I say something and I say another
thing those are not the same length in
terms of the number of kind of time
steps in that audio all of the models
I've shown you thus far though actually
it's hard coded in those models that the
input is a specific size so we need we
need a way around this and the first
potential solution is to make everything
the same size it's actually not as crazy
as it sounds because this is kind of
what people have been doing in computer
vision right like when I go and collect
a million images and I put them into my
database those images aren't all the
same size some of them are 100 by 200
some of them are 400 by 600 pixels and
what I do is I scale them all to 256 by
256 or some nice even number and it
turns out well as you can guess that for
the most part the objects the locations
and the class of the objects within
those images is actually invariant to
deformations like like shrieking horn or
growing the image up to an extent with
audio this is much less so like if I
take 60 seconds of audio and shorten it
to say 20 seconds it's not gonna sound
reasonable to any of you guys and
there's no reason to expect that it's
gonna look reasonable to a machine so
instead we have another solution we we
have a solution to which is trying to
find a model which can actually process
variable length inputs
and the way that we're going to do this
is with a recurrent neural network so
say that I have some audio form looks
like this I'm gonna just bucket it into
three bins three time steps like this
time step zero time step one time step
two time step three and on top of the
first time step I'm just gonna plop a
deep neural network and then on top of
the second time step I'm also gonna plop
a deep neural network and I'm actually
going to have the second time step both
read from input of the audio at the
second time step and the hidden state or
the hidden layer of the network at the
first time step okay and then I can just
do the same thing with the third time
step so you can imagine that I can do
this for an arbitrary number of time
steps so it's called a recurrent Network
because of this kind of recurrence in
the in the layer where it's connecting
almost to itself okay so file this one
away also because this is the
essentially one of the core technologies
that we use with each page okay so what
are some of the challenges you might
encounter as you're trying to scale deep
learning up to your own application well
one of the biggest challenges is
actually coming up with enough data to
train these algorithms effectively and
there's a couple rats you can go here
the first is supervised which you guys
know
and the second is unsupervised so if I
have a data set and I don't have any
labels for that data is then I have a
whole bunch of images but I have no idea
what those images what's in those images
well I can actually try to learn from
that in and it learns I can still
actually try to learn from that in an
unsupervised manner but actually this is
really hard and we haven't made a lot of
progress on this in deep learning so I'm
actually just not going to talk any more
about unsupervised learning we we don't
use it for deep speech yet and we're
mostly pursuing the supervised dread
okay
and within supervised learning I can do
a couple things one I can actually try
to capture more real data or I can
actually synthesize data in a clever way
and I'll explain
those typically so real data is pretty
straightforward like there are a few big
sources of real data but really when it
comes down to it anything you can do to
get your hands on real data you should
try to do so benchmarks are a good
source of this so imagenet is a famous
benchmark where it's it's basically
millions of images more than 14 million
images that all have their corresponding
labels and this benchmark has enabled
like great progress in in computer
vision because it's free and it's
available on its label but unfortunately
for for most problems there is not such
a handy giant benchmark so one thing you
can do is go work for a big company they
have tons of data but I do for example
Amazon Google these guys all have you
know AI labs and they have reams of data
that they're trying to make sense of so
they can bake into their products and
bake some intelligence into their
products another route that you have
which I actually kind of think of as the
dark horse of machine learning research
is is what's called Amazon Mechanical
Turk so you guys familiar with the
Amazon Mechanical Turk ok
well fun fact about Mechanical Turk is
that it's so called because because of
this this this automaton chess-player
built by an inventor in 18th century and
what he did was he built a fake or an
artificial chess playing agent and took
it around to the kings and queens at his
time and telling them that he'd built in
you know an automaton chess-player
he actually had it be like napoleon in
chess I think but turns out that there
was just a man under this box right and
this man was just moving some
contraptions and he was a really good
chess player so that gives you an idea
of why Amazon Mechanical Turk is called
Amazon Mechanical Turk named after this
contraption but I think of Mechanical
Turk is kind of the Dark Horse of
machine learning research because if you
look at a lot of like the most recent
progress and most machine learning
research like a lot of that would not
have been possible without Mechanical
Turk it gives us an efficient and cheap
way of collecting large data sets
without large data sets we can't make
progress
so that's those are kind of some of the
big methods that have for collecting
real data yes oh yeah that's that's good
there are a couple problems with that
it's not a line so it's it's like you
have maybe say half an hour of audio and
a transcription and you don't actually
know when you train these models you
can't train them on such long audio
segments so you need a way of kind of
separating out that audio into like like
30-second clips it's kind of a hard
problem it's not that hard it's solvable
but it's kind of hard bomb another
source that has recently been used is is
are those called
books on tape so there's a data set of
like a thousand hours and books on tape
and they actually have to solve this
problem in order to make it a usable
data set so there's a problem of
proliferation for speech recognition of
these kinds of data sets but nothing on
the scale of imagenet okay so so
synthetic data so one thing that I can
do if I'm in this situation where I can
preserve that the underlying semantics
of this this object without while still
making the data that items look a little
different to the machine so I can take
this house right and if I just translate
the house same I slide it over it's
still a house if I reflect the house
just flip it around its axis still a
house if I rotate it it's still a house
so I can make these kinds of
transformations which preserve the fact
that it's a house and these are just a
small example and I can combinatorially
explode the size of my data set and for
all of these transformations like the
the pixels of this image will look very
very different to a machine and the
pixels of the top image of the house it
actually helps to do these kinds of
things I should say that it doesn't help
nearly as much as typically getting real
data like raw kind of data caught in the
wild but it can help so with speech
recognition what can I do well it's less
clear because in speech recognition it's
less obvious how
can change the underlying signal but
still preserve the transcription right
but one thing I can do is say I have
this snippet of speech so I said the
quick brown fox jumped over the lazy dog
then I have a source of noise so I can
literally take the speech take the noise
add them together quick brown fox is
something that sounds pretty realistic
like it sounds like I was actually in
that noisy environment when I was saying
the quick brown fox jumped over the lazy
dog so this is one way we can try to
make a data set of a bunch of noisy
speech there are other things we can do
but this is perhaps the most
straightforward ok another challenge
with the morning is scale so how do we
train these models as in tune their
internal state so that they can learn to
predict things well how do we do that
efficiently as we get more data you can
imagine that it takes longer to do this
also as we get more data and we we want
to increase the size of the model so
that it has more capacity but that also
is going to leave the longer training
time so the way that we're gonna do this
is by taking advantage of hardware
called the GPU graphics processing units
so you modern-day CPUs are I guess
capable of you know computing at around
100 Giga floating-point operations per
second so floating-point operations like
addition multiplication things like that
now if I look at a CPU sorry a GPU it's
almost like an order of magnitude and a
half better than that no GPU is not like
a panacea I could just take a CPU plop
in the GPU and things will just run
faster I actually need a very specific
type of computation that Maps well to
the GPU and the computation has to be of
this sort where the instruction that I'm
giving is typically the same and it just
has to operate on many different
instances of this data what's called a
like same instruction multiple data
and this this type of computation that's
really really well to this type of
hardware and it so turns out also that
deep learning which is mostly like when
you look into the kind of the guts of
deep learning it's mostly matrix
multiplies Maps also very well onto this
hardware ok so we're going to use GPUs
and of course one GPU is not enough for
us so we're just going to get a whole
bunch of GPUs and we're gonna wire them
all together with super fast networking
technologies so InfiniBand here is one
such networking technology known for its
really a little bit and it seemed really
high throughput really high so this is
kind of what we could have we can
imagine one kind of popu cluster looking
like where we have several GPUs on a
machine and they're all they're all
communicating with each other via super
fast mode so it needs to be able to talk
to each other really quickly ok so a few
of you might be familiar with this
Google brain project that was out of
control I think in 2012 actually and
ruing professor here and divided
research he started this project at
Google and what they did there was they
built this giant neural network a
network that had a billion parameters
and and it was trained on many many
millions of images and it had billions
of connections so billions of those
synapses that you saw earlier and the
way that they were able to compute this
thing efficiently on it their huge data
set was by distributing this computation
across 16,000 CPU cores that's a lot of
CPU cores so actually atom code so I
mentioned earlier
Brody Duvall who's actually here at
Stanford and and Brian Kenton Sarah
who's also at by do research they they
had the insight that perhaps we can do
this much much faster
if we use GPUs and and then have them
communicate with each other in the right
way
and they were able to take this problem
and actually do the same thing that the
Google brain had done with 16,000 CPU
cores like literally replicate this
problem and do it with only 12 GPUs
and so not only do they need way fewer
machines but this actually costs way
less money enables people you know
without the infrastructure of Google and
the resources to recreate this kind of
work I didn't tell you off the top of my
head I'd imagine it's pretty pretty
large then yeah the the way that the the
CPU cores were being used was not a way
to minimize power I don't know what
those are but you guys any questions
about the point there about kind of the
overview that I just gave are the
numerical operands and the GPUs
floating-point numbers or are they small
integers floating point numbers 32-bit
floating-point numbers typically look
people are doing work to see if it to
make them smaller yes the classification
is essentially free independent of the
model the classification what do you
mean so you train your model yes then
you give it samples and they the model
needs to classify them right this is
this much cheaper than learning yes the
type of so training is what we care
about more because it bottlenecks are
rate of research so we'd like to be able
to train them quickly so that we can
kind of make a lot of progress quickly
but when we're actually trying to deploy
these things in real products that's
when we care about doing fast by
summation and it's a totally different
type of problem which I'm not going to
get into but it's not done at all the
way that I just described typically yeah
yes
avoid this four products does it have to
pump the Davis center and get a computer
and then faster back to this or is it
actually localized unit on the yeah
usually it's computing things are
computed in the cloud it depends on the
task
so for voice is typically done a little
bit on both so when I actually get the
full signal I'm gonna send that to the
club to my transcription send the
transcription back but sometimes you
might notice that like if you want your
phone to recognize when you say ok
Google like you want it to wake up that
is not going to the cloud that's often
done and I'm like a little tiny
processor on the phone yeah I think so
but I'm not really sure yeah I think
like it would be great if we could
compute these things on the phone like
itself but we're still a long ways away
from doing that so like not only do we
use a lot of computer but we also use a
lot of memory for these models the
memory is pretty easy when we had what
big data centers but it's it's a little
less easy when you have yeah so there's
some of them do a lot of this each your
mom saw it logistically yeah you can
totally think of a a single neuron is
exactly we're just a great that's good
yeah your budgets why couldn't use the
synthesizer speech to train - oh it's
not crazy one of my one of my colleagues
has been suggesting we do this for a
really long time as in like take a take
a you know the speech the text-to-speech
module record that or something and then
feed that that's a train yours and I
think so there will be what you might
encounter which I would predict is that
there are a lot of subtle differences
between what that signal looks like and
what signal from a real human
looks like and thus you will hit a
pretty high ceiling in terms of
performance doing it that way
that would be what I'm pretty but you
could go to 75% other than there sure
you could augment your data that way do
you guys do any semi-supervised learning
is that useful
yeah it's useful and no we don't do it
yet yeah but I didn't I mean happy - yes
no we don't always use fully connected
networks I'll show you an image of our
model in a second actually the first
layer is a competition okay so I think
there are I don't know too much about
them yes thank you so deep speech
okay so deep speech as I mentioned
earlier it's kind of our latest
technology and using deep learning kind
of trying to replace the speech pipeline
with mostly deep learning okay and at
the core of deep speech are two big
ingredients so trying to address the two
main challenges that I mentioned earlier
with deep learning the first is data
the second is scale before I talk about
these two things so I want to briefly
show you what the model actually looks
like okay so what we have here is this
is a spectrogram and essentially you can
think of it as taking our raw audio
waveform that you saw earlier and when
doing that and computing a Fourier
transform of each of those windows so
that's exactly what this is nothing more
like MATLAB Python they all have modules
and they spectrogram modules like that's
what we're using very well-developed
technology so that's the input to the
model then we feed it into these layers
and this is actually a convolution for
those of you that know about that and
not that important though and then this
into the next layers those are all
densely connected and then up top where
I can't reach we have where the blue and
red arrows are we have the recurrent
layer so I showed you the recurrent
Network earlier and this is like not
actually any more complex than that the
model I showed you earlier the only
difference is is we have two directions
in the recurrent layer so we both are
taking information from the past and
using that to inform ourselves but we're
also taking information from the future
so time step T I might also include
information from time step T plus one so
the next thing I do is aggregate both
the forward chain and the back chain in
time at the next layer and then I make a
prediction and what I'm going to predict
here is a letter in the alphabet so the
deep speech system is what's called a
graphene based system where a graphene
is the smallest unit of the the smallest
unit of symbols in your written language
right so it's a graphing based system so
we're in this case because it's English
we're predicting letters in our alphabet
plus a few punctuation marks the space
symbol as well so you can see here from
Ross spectrogram to transcription we're
going straight from Ross spectrogram to
transcription now it's not this simple
we actually also include the constraints
of a language model at the very end I'm
not going to picture that here but so we
haven't totally replaced everything I
just want to make that point but we're
this is like a step in that direction
so one thing that's interesting about
this model is that there's actually no
alignment needed for it and actually
more specifically when we have this
audio is say it's like a hundred time
steps if you will we don't necessarily
have a hundred output characters in our
transcription like like the sentence
that I said is not made up of a hundred
characters it's probably made up of like
twenty characters so what I'm going to
allow the model to do is actually output
a no op essentially or output a blank as
in I predict that you
nothing in this time step and then what
I'm going to do is take the series of
blanks letters repeat letters and I'm
going to collapse it as follows I'm just
gonna yank out all the blanks and repeat
letters which are not separated by blank
I'm just gonna collapse into one letter
and then that becomes this here okay so
you can see both of these things map
onto the cat this is an algorithm we use
an algorithm called CTC which was
developed by graves at all in like oh
six so you can read more about it from
there so back to the key ingredients of
D so data right so we have access to
some public benchmarks and this gives us
about like 2000 hours of speech but
that's not enough for deep speech deep
speech has a big appetite for data so we
actually have about five more thousand
hours of our own data that we added into
the mix
and this gave us a total of seven
thousand hours of raw data to train our
model this is not a crazy amount of data
like most state-of-the-art recognizers
train their their algorithms on between
5,000 and say 10000 hours of data so
this were like in the ballpark there of
like the biggest data sets but what we
did is we actually then took that 7,000
hours and we added about a hundred
thousand hours of synthesized data and
the way that we did this was by finding
like scouring the web for a bunch of raw
audio like any kind of audio not
specifically speech and then taking all
of those segments that we found say 10
at a time summing them all up and that
sum of 10 raw audio segments would be a1
noise example so if you listen to that
it sounds a lot like real background
noise like background noise that you
would actually encounter in real life
and we took that noise example and we
added it to our speech signal and then
we did this in many different ways for
each speech signal and this allowed us
to train our model on about a hundred
thousand hours of new examples but keep
in mind that this is not a hundred
thousand hours of raw real data it's
it's a hundred thousand hours of
synthesized data it's not quite as good
as if we had a hundred thousand dollars
of real did
okay so scaling how do we scale this
model well one thing that is let me
briefly go through this we're running
low on time so the bottleneck of this
algorithm is actually the recurrent
layer and it might be clear because you
can kind of see that there's a
sequential dependency between each time
step so it's really hard to break this
model up and paralyze it in the
recurrent layer like these layers are
actually pretty easy because they're
totally independent they can be computed
quickly but the recurrent layer like the
forward recurrent layer it's totally
sequential the backward recurrent layer
is totally sequential so you might think
that maybe we can we might make the
observation that the blue nodes are
independent of the red nodes so we can
compute those independently we could
have one processor work on the forward
Direction one processor work on the
backward direction and that would speed
up the time by two problem with this
method is it's not clear from this image
is that if I do it this way I actually
have to communicate a lot of information
between my two processors and so that's
going to slow me down more than it's
worth
so instead what we do is we just cut the
model in two like literally in half and
we have the first processor work on the
left at the first GPU the second GPU
works on the right half and the way that
this works is the first GPU goes in the
forward time step up until it gets to
the middle the second TPU goes backwards
up until it gets to the middle and then
they exchange a tiny little bit of
information when they both reach the
middle and then they switch and then the
forward process does the first process
does the the rest of the backward layer
and this the second process does the
rest of the forward layer so doing it
this way enables us to very much
minimize the amount of communication at
a very little cost and thus we're able
to get basically a 2x improvement now
this isn't the only thing that we did
it's kind of the most interesting
perhaps way that we've scaled this
problem but we actually do a lot of
other things which I'm not going to go
into because we don't have time but if
we take a look at some of the results so
deep speech this is this is a results in
terms of the metric here is word error
rate so this is like an edit distance
between the words in my output my guest
transcription in the words and my ground
truth transcription
and if we look at where area and
benchmark our self against some of the
best speech recognizers in the world say
like the Google's the Microsoft's apples
the the technology that powers Apple
Siri with that AI which is a smaller
start-up but actually has really good
speech technology they're actually now
recently bought by Facebook we actually
don't do that much better than these
guys in the clean speech setting when I
say clean I mean when there's no
background noise but if you look at the
noisy speech that's where deep speech
really shocked so we've really made a
lot of progress there
I think the point though is you know
we've made a lot of progress but noisy
speech is still much much worse than
clean speech and you as a human
presumably can do much much better and
this is actually true you could do much
much better so we still have a long ways
to go okay so that's that's what's going
on with deep speech yes it was the
performance measure on that graph word
every word error rate yeah so that's
that's what I was saying earlier it's
like the Edit distance between the guest
transcription and the ground truth
transcription as in the number of
insertions at a distance you can look
that up at a distance the benchmark was
a test dataset that we collected yes we
did not train it on the noisy data then
we created this is that what you mean
based on your created oh sure the noisy
thing that we created we trained our
network on but when we actually tested
it we tested it on real data with real
noise that we had not seen right so
we're not cheating in this case at least
we don't think we are okay so next step
so briefly next ups for deep speech I
think we haven't tapped out the more
data the more the bigger model source of
improvement I also don't think that that
our algorithm is necessarily the speech
algorithm I think there are is a lot of
room and probably will have to be
algorithmic innovations to really solve
speech recognition
and lastly I myself think that
unsupervised learning is also going to
be really important to unlocking speech
recognition yeah I think if you look at
humans like we listen to audio all the
time right we're constantly synthesizing
and integrating information from audio
and we do this in a totally unsupervised
manner so I think there's a lot of room
to explore that so for you guys if
you're interested to learn more about
deep learning or about any any of these
topics really so there's machine
learning class Andrews class here
entering and and he also has the same
class or a similar class on Coursera
back when I was at Stanford actually
worked on the deep learning tutorial
which I highly encourage you to take a
look at if you're interested in the
technical details of deep learning and
if you want to read about deep speech
there's a there's a link there to our
cut
you